this statement comes directly from Mark
Zuckerberg mark wrote the statement and
it says the Palmers have a post and it
says I'm supporting Gary Johnson on that
note you gave me the segue that I needed
already so the new book is the history
of the future it's oculus Facebook and
the revolution that swept virtual
reality for people that have no idea I
think people have certain set of people
of a certain age have a certain sense of
what virtual reality is maybe their son
or grandchild has you know PlayStation
VR which I just test it out for the
first time nephews who's pretty awesome
all I played was that game that first
game that it comes with that you know
which is sort of like a Mario Brothers
knockoff and I was like this is yeah
this is pretty freakin awesome so yeah
so to explain just what I went yeah
virtual reality the concept and even
demos have been around since the 1960s
it's it's basically this idea of putting
on glasses or goggles or a headset or
what everyone call it song that's
covering your eyes and and you all you
see is a computer-generated world and so
back to the 1960s 1980s you know even
just the graphics of like a PlayStation
in the 90s it's like very blocky polygon
graphics you know it doesn't really feel
real it doesn't even feel like a
animated Pixar quality like movie but
then nowadays you know or I guess I
should just begin by saying that virtual
reality was considered dead and like a
waste of time back in 2012 it was like
really you know a technological
punchline like flying cars or jet packs
it's like a sci-fi trope like we all
thought was gonna happen we were so
stupid right like the ship sailed like
if it was gonna happen it made sure that
because Nintendo did try to do that well
boy yeah Virtual Boy which was a very
weird run because it was like it was
actually like a red-colored yeah thing
and you seat your head into it like this
Sega actually had a VR headset that they
were going to release but there was
health concerns so no it's been in the
ether of gaming it's been in the
periphery and the reason it never worked
is many fold but largely because it just
has never worked and you never can't go
to be seized and say oh look this is
weird like you may sit there like here
we have 50 years of failure and then
they would look you like alright well
why do you think you're going to succeed
was it partly just purely cost I mean I
know everything starts off expensive and
then
more people adopted it gets cheaper but
I remember in 1992 going on a family
vacation to Toronto and they had like a
Nintendo expose I think was called
Nintendo World and they had this
offshoot VR thing where we put on I
remember doing it we put on this giant
helmet we were in this like circle thing
and it was me and my brother and we had
to shoot each other and it was awesome
it was blocky and pixelated and all that
but it was cool as hell like you kind of
felt like you were gonna fall off a
ledge alas up but it was a my point is
that it was a lot of equipment it was a
lot of write-off that would have cost a
ton of money when you're trying to get
these into kids homes when the system
itself only costs 80 bucks well well
they had like I described these blocky
and polygons like like a PlayStation
game so people look back and like I of
course failed and then it's like no we
were playing games of that quality on
PlayStation that was cutting-edge to us
so hmm that wasn't why I failed and and
I thought it was cool like if you had
pulled me aside in like 1994 like hey
kid
ah I don't know some creepy no you're
like hey kid I'm from the future
yeah Virtual Reality it's me the biggest
thing in the world I'd be like duh of
course like like we all know that that's
happening so I and I wasn't particularly
into it it just seemed so obvious it was
you know there was movies like long
Laura Mahan there was just more and more
like seems like a part of our lives it
was in the mall and you're at home
consumer sort of console version was way
too expensive but the way that succeeded
at first or became sort of ubiquitous
was the the location-based like at malls
you pay $15 and you go put your brother
and there's probably good use of money
and your parents were happy to have you
go in there but that ended because the
market just dried up they were losing
money on this and vrm was left for dead
and then in 2012 or between 2009 and
2012 a 16 year old kid in 2009 19 year
old kid in 2012 named Palmer Luckey was
obsessed with VR he was a you know a
self-taught engineer slash tinkerer who
loved modifying old consoles and
actually portable eyes about consoles
like him and his buddies would take up
your Nintendo and figure out how can we
make the smallest version that you can
bring on the go with you so he was
almost like uniquely talented to be
dealing with retro console
but with uh you know he is a genius
level talent and so he spent three years
my book begins in 2012 he's living in a
trailer in Long Beach California the
trailers parked at his parents driveway
because they had kicked him out of the
house but he stayed right off the
property yeah thank you I remember him
telling me I was like like tell me what
the trailer looked like and he had got
in the kitchen and it was basically just
this mad scientist laboratory of
building vr headsets and I was like this
sounds a lot like Walter White's methane
curated for VR headsets instead of meth
and he's like yeah that's pretty much
exactly it so you got this image of this
19 year old mad scientist genius guy
working on this technology that no one
cares about like even his friends who
love gaming are like dude VR VR died but
he loved it and you know he created this
prototype that was like that could be
made for a few hundred dollars and and
even at that time you know it's been 10
20 years since what you were talking
about like like the best VR headsets
would still cost $5,000 or $10,000 and
he created something that was better
than all that and cost a few hundred
dollars and then he is sort of like
being discovered moment was this game
maker named John Carmack who's one of
the most legendary candy makers he's
responsible for doing Wolfenstein and
quake and all that you know it's
software and he you know he had licensed
those games in the 90s to VR companies
that wanted to make you know like
location-based stuff and it sucked and
he and you know John Carmack he he he's
probably been smarter than Palmer he is
a real genius he after whenever he
finishes a game he takes a little R&D
period where he investigates some
unknown technology or you know unknown
technology one time this resulted him
starting an aerospace company because
he's just like oh I spent a few weeks
learning you know rocket said why not
why not so he learned the rocket science
started company and so in 2012 after
he's in it or late 2011 after finish
this game called rage he was like oh
virtual reality whatever happened it's
been so long I must have forgot so much
since I last looked at this and he
realized like no it's just as bad and
like it's such a combat thing to say he
told me he's like I was actually
offended by
how but had not progressed as like a as
a technologist as an idealist and then
he was searching on the internet he
heard about this you know this is uh his
hardware hacker named Palmer Tech Palmer
Luckey
he got in touch it's him he asked to
borrow his headset and then he was
really impressed he ended up bringing it
to the annual trade show III and 2012
and I demo it and it was like it won
like so many awards and it was this you
know homemade thing competing against
like the millions of billions of dollars
billion dollar boots and billion dollar
products with Nintendo and Sony and all
that and then that's sort of you know is
what led to the beginning of oculus
and-and-and Palmer Luckey bursting onto
the scene back there's a lot to go I
could go in a lot of different
directions there so now VR has had this
sort of rebirth and people are people
are using again and they're using it not
only for gaming but for all sorts of
things
how did what what's the face book part
of this story yeah
so partly also to answer your question
of like why didn't it work before I made
a lot of it is just technology you know
Morris lot of things get better Palmer
Luckey would be the first to say that if
not for the advances in cell phone
technology with tracking and the screens
like he wouldn't succeed it if he had
been born 20 years earlier he wouldn't
have been so lucky okay there I said use
the pun uh it was really hard in the
book to avoid using like that must have
been different it was proud to say it
ever did but but you know the technology
was such a big part of it and and really
like ever everyone who is in the VR
space is visionary very few people then
a lot of people now they all you know
it's all the same end goal or you could
put on a headset and potentially have an
experience like The Matrix and it would
be like you know as thin as classes like
this and it would be as real as the
matrix but it's really just a matter of
how do we get there and how do we do it
in a way where you can monetize it and
what I thought was so cool about oculus
and why I was interested in writing the
book was the they thought the video
games were the way in it wasn't like
powers I got video games is the whole
point of the art was actually
gamers tend to have a lot of disposable
income and they're willing to spend it
on higher-end things so we can sell
these headsets for $300
games and it was like this is the
perfect market this is a perfect
stepping stone to get to where we want
VR to go this is how we grow the
industry and so they launched a
Kickstarter and on August 1st 2012
they're trying to raise $400,000 they
raise to half a million
their slogan because we know that the
marketing promotions report it was step
into the game and that was created by
Palmer's co-founders they've sort of
brought this business marketing savvy to
the whole thing you know it was a great
peanut butter and jelly combination with
Palmer being the hardware maker and then
being they had background they were
software makers and and that and so you
know I was I was really fascinated by
using gaming as the way in to growing
this technology and then in a surprise
to me and to most people in 2014 so less
than two years after the company was
founded they sold the Facebook for three
billion dollars and you know one of the
reasons they did that was just because
the resources that Facebook was give
them you know we're basically like we
don't need to make money for the
foreseeable future like we will and
Facebook will make this investments but
Facebook also went away from gaming for
all the reasons they'll get into other
which is like the culture old gamergate
like this is a toxic white male space
that we don't want to be in or it's only
awful white male neo-nazis play video
yeah it was like yeah so you know like
obviously that's not true also that's
just a really stupid business strategy
because you know one of the things this
is flashing forward a bit but like
before so I got incredible access for
the book anyone who's read anything I've
written I like to tell character-driven
stories and I can't do it without access
I would never write a book about your
life without you know some way that I
was gonna get a lot of members of you
ideally are a lot of archival texts and
emails and all that you know I'm still
writing it independently but I just
couldn't imagine doing it without that
because how else can I put readers in
the room with you and in your head and
so I got this incredible access that
lasted for two and a half years and
ended for the reasons that we'll
definitely get to but my last visit to
Facebook's campus in Menlo Park was a
February of 2018 and I remember talking
to the two new heads of oculus after the
founders were no longer in charge and
one of them had
presided over Android going from 25
million to a billion users and the other
was a guy who actually used Ben marks ta
back in college and had joined the
company really early on and talked about
how originally they had been so
successful in colleges you know and then
they went mainstream and both of them
talked about like we're now at this
point where we've already succeeded with
gamers and now we're going mainstream
and it was like it just reminds me sort
of like the et thing where it's like no
you're putting the cart before the words
you just assume success and then you
move on to the next I'm like I know so
many gamers who hate you who think you
guys are doing a terrible job and
fortunately I think Facebook has
actually gravitated back more towards
the gaming evil attacks a gamer space
but it's just it was just interesting to
look at that lens and I never would have
thought I never thought the cultural
aspect would be a part of my story and
of course it became a huge part of the
story because Palmer Luckey got fired in
the middle by writing the book right so
okay can you explain that because that
then sort of that connects all of this
for the for the average person that's
what that watches my show normally
that's like this show is a little
offbeat for what you normally do which
is completely fine but this now is sort
of work who's gonna link it to almost
everything else yeah so the story of my
life the past few years I mean so so
Palmer was the the founder the visionary
of oculus he was 19 years old he was 21
they sold it he's a brilliant
charismatic guy he was the face of
Industry imported character and and so
he also happened to be a trump supporter
and originally this was something that
he was like like there's a video from
February of 2016 of there was a trump
rally and he appeared on an NBC news
piece and was a at the Trump rally let
me get this straight
this man supported the President of the
United States and I expects to have a
job and be a functioning member of
society is that what you're telling yes
I can't believe we're even do you know
like of course there should be nothing
wrong with him openly publicly
supporting one of the two major party
system but then I noticed he stopped
publicly doing it and what happened was
the only other person in Silicon Valley
who publicly supported Trump and this is
not my words this is Marc Andreessen the
most famous VC has talked about how he's
only actually
- out out Trump sputters Pierre teal and
Palmer Luckey and Peter teal you know
spoke at the RNC and he's Peter Thiel's
famous for PayPal but also being the
first investor in facebook I've been
bored of Facebook and all across
Facebook campus people fought so hard to
get him fired for the crime of
supporting Trump and speaking at the RNC
and so powers like okay well I should
probably not be so public about this
because this is what will happen to me
and that was both foreshadowing and also
important because what happened was in
September of 2016 so this was two months
before the election Palmer
donated a little bit less than ten
thousand dollars to an organization
called nimble America nimble America's
goal was to put up billboards across the
country really really wild stuff they
they're like what ended up getting them
into trouble was that they spoke in the
parlance of the Donald subreddit and
they said you know we have proved that
me magic is real we're gonna shitpost
across America in which they just meant
we the Royal we Donald and like we're
going to put up billboards the only
billboard named America ever put up in
its entire existence was a billboard a
slightly characterized image of Hillary
Clinton's face with the headline too big
to jail so so just just to be clear in
case people are missing so this because
there's so much here all they he gave
10,000 dollars to this company they were
gonna put up billboards that we're gonna
just put memes up so the memes that had
been sort of bouncing all over the
internet that's all they were doing like
I'm not even like well we'll get it
because the memes were the things that
actually were we're fueling the Trump
campaign but all but a lot of them were
just shitposting kids coming up with
money and and memes like to me I think
there's a very Internet aspect to it
like when you're actually putting up
physical billboards they're just called
advertise right I mean they might look
like memes or whatever right but I guess
we'd say modern you can't share that you
lose some of the magic let's say yeah
but like and then also talking to the
founders of America because this would
become an issue in a second I'll get to
but like you know the way okay well
let's just say what happens next so on
September 22nd
20:16 The Daily Beast comes out with an
article about Palmer and the headline is
Facebook billionaire secretly funding
Trump's meme machine and the insinuation
was that every terrible meme that you've
seen online during this past election
season everything transphobic
concentration camps anti-semitic
all this stuff Palmer Luckey was the guy
funding at all and if you didn't get
that from the headline and the article
this this tech blogger named Daniel -
explicitly that guy he does not he's no
fan of mine he's no phantom yeah yeah
because I was tweeting about our food
that I think up who should be allowed to
be in the Simpsons and he told me I'm
racist and yeah well he was kinder to
you than to me alright um yeah because I
want my job as a journalist just to
speak with all the people involved in
this so I wanted to hear his side of the
story because he did post that Facebook
the pawn was using his billions remember
10 does not the money thing is
irrelevant the fact is that this
organization with the Palmer gave $1 or
million dollars they weren't doing
anything inappropriate right and and he
said the Palmer responsible for every
white supremacist name that you'd seen
and we've got a poster saying you're
telling me Daily Beast did something
that didn't have great and journalists
integrity speak you Terry here's an
interesting thing and and I tried to
handle it neck secure to tell me
BuzzFeed's up to this I can't believe it
so what happened actually the way that
it all played out was Palmer donated to
nibble America they because he was doing
an anonymously after learning from the
Peter Thiel situation his his moniker
there was nimble rich man that they said
we have a wealthy benefactor that they
thought this would give legitimacy to
the organization people on reddit said
oh you don't really have a wealthy
backer they got mildly innopolis who was
a moderator you know popular on the
Donald to verify that Palmer exists did
not say his name and basically like I
have confirmed that there is a wealthy
person so the nimble thing the noble
America thing launched in September 17th
few days later
Gideon Resnick from The Daily Beast
emails Milo and I always just found it
funny because you know he likes these
hippies on Milo fair or not but just
he's so friendly he's like anybody like
how's it gone well yeah but that's what
they always did I know I don't think
people know that I think they always do
that but yeah because I included the
emails in the book but so he contacts
milo and says what's the deal with this
nimble america thing up the previous
month Gideon Resnick had written an
article about how Milo's privileged
scholarship thing was a scam I have no
idea whether it was or not but Milo
interpreted as a hit piece and assumed
that Gideon was gonna write another hit
piece Milo said I have no affiliation
with this thing other than I verified
that there was a wealthy person
Gideon keeps pressing Milo acids Palmer
if he could reveal his name so that Milo
is off the hot seat Palmer they end up
basically agreeing that Palmer will like
reveal himself as long as there's no
article written or if there's an article
in his identity is kept secret crisis is
like talking about Batman and Bruce
Wayne okay but anyway that agreement was
struck the Gideon dressing for The Daily
Beast said sure he would do this
anonymously
he ended up revealing powers name now I
like I said it was difficult for me to
hand on the book because like I think at
the end of the day all that someone like
my mom or most viewers should care about
is like what happened not fruit from the
forbidden tree that's like procedural
stuff that you and I as journalists and
storytellers can care about but like the
average person should just care about
what did Palmer actually do what did he
donate to news organization so I don't
want to focus too much on that but I
just was like disgusted Daily Beast not
surprising and then of course within a
matter of hours after the article
claimed that Palmer's response were
other stuff every single tech press you
know every it just it was really just
that game of telephone that we all know
happens but it was like to actually look
at the headlines I once line them up you
know you have this Palmer Luckey
secretly funding Trump's main machine
then Ars Technica a few hours later
Palmer Luckey usually secretly funding
Trump's a racist to me a machine yeah
same exact timeline but let's throw in
the word racism just and it's just like
asleep like that well yeah it's so funny
because just as you're saying this what
popped into my head was so our our
friend Colin Moriarty
you know the show many times and when he
got into hot water over his tweet which
was you know International Women's they
finally a little peace and quiet
Business Insider rang the head
was Colin Moriarty of what was his old
company yeah kind of funny his his
racist tweet which is so funny because I
thought it had nothing to grind it's
racism racism and sexism are real
problems and but you know I identify
myself as a little hairlike and and and
they are just used as like synonymous
buzzwords like oh you did something bad
that was a racist comment you can
acknowledge that they are real things
but that doesn't mean they're the same
thing there's still different things
yeah but this sort of thing then where
the media then catches on and it spreads
like wildfire and they just replicate
headlines and the rest of it and and we
can get into that and the fake news and
all that because that is important but
here's the real [ __ ] up part of the
story so all of this is happening I
would you know the next day what you
know the press culminates the next day
with Wired yeah I would've thought the
most of them involve tech press out
there they have a headline Palmer Luckey
is the worst but he doesn't represent
Silicon Valley like just on news she's
the worst yeah for supporting Trump but
anyway you can imagine the firestorm at
Facebook this is a public figure this is
your young charismatic chosen one and he
is being called a racist he's being
called the worst person on the internet
people are saying boycott oculus all
this stuff real PR disasters and I
sympathetic that but so what happened
was you know Palmer that one of the
biggest influences life is debate and so
he one of these everything like about
him is that he's always willing to talk
things out he doesn't just have his
opinion saying well that's my right so
his response was to write a public
statement and explain like um most of
the stuff is not true here's what is
true here's what's not true like it's a
very Palmer like way of dealing with
this and and he described that this
organization in ball America he donated
them because they have principles of
like you know so he wanted to put an end
to America's like never-ending Wars and
the millions people dying which also
becomes relevant with the company
started after this but like you know it
certainly didn't persuade me to vote for
Trump but it was at least like he wasn't
just like no let's straight liberals
here's like he had a reason
uh he had to read he had as a reason for
this and and explained why he supported
Trump
Facebook would not let him put that must
that's a job this news all hit at 6:00
p.m. what Pacific time on on a Thursday
I think Pomeroy statement almost right
away wanted to put it up Facebook
wouldn't let him say he supported Trump
unbelievable I mean really it's so I
mean it's crazy again at that point
Trump is one of two people and a
two-party system who I personally
despise but I also more importantly
everyone to be able to support any
candidate they want especially an on
verge candidate wait I hate to do this
but our schedule is so not say so we
have to summit could we do this all in
five minutes is that a yes yeah let's
try said five so anyway the next Palmer
is dying to get the statement out you
know every hour and new articles coming
out and then finally he gets a statement
that he is told to post and this
statement comes directly from Mark
Zuckerberg mark wrote the statement and
it says the Palmer's in the post and it
says I'm supporting Gary Johnson
so Palmer is being told to lie about his
politics and say they supporting Harry
Johnson and Palmer of course doesn't
want to do this but he's totally fired
if he doesn't do it so he does that and
that's illegal in California also really
unethical
wait what what's illegal to force
someone to lie about their political
beliefs in a public statement that
Palmer is put on suspension for the next
six months I mean he is ends up being
fired but I just could not believe that
mark personally he wrote a statement
that you know so it was so intolerable
to support Trump that he had to say that
he was supporting Gary Johnson and then
that also was terrible for his
reputation what was left to because yeah
the liberal mainstream press went after
him with the racist [ __ ] but then
all the bag of people who just like
about a headset because I want to
support you they're all like oh he's
like either a coward or he really is a
Gary Johnson I think he's an idiot
mm-hmm you must have talked to him about
why he didn't just take whatever money
he had gotten already and just walk well
there was a heavy very careful things I
talked to them and obviously signed
agreements but I have
I have a very close relationship I'm
spoke with him almost every day for the
past three years and fortunately people
at Facebook thought what happened was so
messed up they were really helpful to
getting me internal documents so I was
able to piece together the story get
marks actual email forcing Palmer to lie
about his political beliefs and and and
but the short answer is your question
that I have never been able to actually
ask him but it's because he was he
would've done anything to stay back to
us like he baby yeah it was a baby like
at one point after they they they try
and fire him and give him none of his
remaining vesting money basically it was
a back loaded deal he said okay I'll
work there for free but they wouldn't
let him continue to work there like he
just it was it was everything yeah it's
like it's like Silicon Valley on HBO
yeah bananas yeah there's so much more
here then there's such there's such a
connection between this there's less I
will gladly have you back I mean this
last 15 minutes especially it's so
connective to so many of the things I
talk about related to the tech world
free speech and politics and the mob and
all of these things so it's it's it's
fascinating a week council words like I
was the darling of the tech press world
I wrote this book it was being turned
into a movie most people like the book
because I think it was very well written
but all just because it was a Sega
Nintendo thing it is now July the books
been out for four months it has there
still has not been a single review of
the book not a single person in the tech
or gaming community has acknowledged my
book god these awful freaks
fortunately yeah we're right so we're
deck yeah has promoted the hell out of
it had me on a few times and the book
went up to number two on all of Amazon
which totally kicked the butt of my
first book so guys this book guys I
would sold my first book which was the
best Sonic game book video game of all
time and there still is not been a
single review I wonder why
all right well I don't write book
reviews but we will link to should we
link to Amazon does that where you
wanted to link we will link to Amazon
for this book we'll do this again
because there's so much more here and
it's so connected to some of those other
things we'll stream some video games or
something cuz especially especially if
you're not very good it would be a
pleasure yeah beat us up yeah
it's been fun there's a lot more here
obviously for more on Blake follow him
on the Twitter machine at Blake Jay
Harris NYC
[Music]